[Music]
hey chuck
hey neil how's it going yeah about this
time of year your name
shows up i see it in emails and in
announcements and
you're like hosting earth day
events that i'm just proud of you for
being out there on this
thank you thank you yes i'm very much an
advocate for the
um uh finding a solution to the climate
crisis
wait but charles did anyone remind you
you are a comedian
so you don't have to do this yes and i
have to tell you though
it's funny you say that because
sometimes i'll have i'll be a part of
these symposiums and things and it'll be
like
dr this doctor this you know the head of
this uh
um this government branch this
government branch
and comedian chuck nice and everybody is
like what the hell is he doing
what is he doing here
all right but we love you and we know we
know that you're
you're where you need to be because that
you need somebody to make it real right
yeah well this time of year this is a
great time of year because we always
acknowledge
earth day and you know right everybody
everybody's
everybody's familiar with earth day but
it's funny the
like if i were to ask my kids where did
earth day come from
they wouldn't know like you know what i
mean but they know every day every year
because in school oh it's earth day
we're going to have earth day
right and so i always thought it's a
little weird that we celebrate earth
right does earth know or care you know
oh it gives us life it gives us food and
but
there's no like refrigerator day that's
where i get my food
right yeah happy fridge day you know oh
yeah i had a good one man
mine's full up so it is a little odd but
if we if we sort of unpack all of this
and go back in time uh the first earth
day was 1970.
that's 50 years ago dude man
i was i was and i'm so old i was around
back then
just okay you know okay that's how old i
am that's how old i am i was here for
the first
earth day i walked to the first earth
day both ways up here
that's it that's a rocking chair on the
porch story right there
very
it was so long ago that we called it
proto-planet day
so so anyway so the first was 1970 so
you can ask well
what what was what was going on right
well
if you go back a few years earlier i
think when was in 1962
rachel carson published a book called
silent spring
and many people know about this book
especially environmentalists
and many people sort of trace the birth
of the modern
environmental movement to that book what
it did was it
it highlighted the causes and effects of
things we are doing
in our environment to our food stocks
all right it's particularly highlighted
ddt
as a pesticide you know i had a noble
cause i don't want insects
eating my food right i want to eat the
food let's get rid of the insects here's
a chemical
that was had recently recently been
invented just a couple of i think the
late 30s 1940s
it was a new chemical that had this
effect on insects
well what effect does it have on you all
right and so here's
or the environment or the soils so it
was an exploration
of the causes and effects of our actions
subsequently banned too right
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah so but we can
ask when was it banned
the book came out in 62 was it banned in
63 no 64
no 65 no no so we'll get to that so that
happened
meanwhile there are also these like uh
pollution
incidences all right pollutive moments
in the news
like uh a lake dies that is the fishes
in the lake died because
some factory was pumping pollutants into
the lake
or a stream gets polluted so we had a
sense
that there was pollution in the
environment air pollution was there
but no one really thought globally about
it
right all right you say that i'll clean
up the stream and everything will be
fine
let's fix the lake this my lake is in my
backyard let's fix it this is pollution
just over this city
let's just fix that and all will be fine
and no one is thinking as carl sagan
said
that maybe air molecules don't have to
carry passports
to move around the earth water molecules
that that are contaminated here go into
the ground they infect the water table
they'll go into the ocean
travels the world we are not
isolated on this planet and that concept
was not widely embraced in the 1960s or
at any time before
so so what happens okay
let's keep going in time oh by the way
there was a congressional
committee set up to talk about the
things that rachel carson warned about
but nothing there was no legislation
that came out of that it was in the few
years that followed because it was a
best-selling book
and people were talking about it so
let's keep moving uh the years unfold
1965. oh by the way the vietnam war is
building
all right uh and and our presence there
so the
the hot war in southeast asia the cold
war with the soviet union
so we have oh and the civil rights
movement
all right we got issues that are
preoccupying us
no matter so much good music came out of
the 60s and the 60s
okay and motown yes
[Laughter]
people needed it man that was an escape
all right so here's so the 60s was a
particularly
turbulent decade in american history
perhaps the most turbulent
since the civil war 100 years earlier
so did we simply not have the bandwidth
to say oh
here i am i'm you know i'm protesting
for civil rights oh now let me
think about ddt right this is you know
what is
what is people's bandwidth to think
about problems now here's what happens
1968 uh apollo 8
is the first time anyone ever leaves
earth
and you know where they go they go to
the moon to leave earth
for a destination right they go to the
moon december
1968. and to me that was the most
significant of all space missions ever
flown
and based on all the problems that were
down here on earth i am surprised they
came back
nick didn't say let's pitch tent
wherever we go yeah
jesus what are we going back to that
place for
ddt and war and civil rights and
god so they go out to the moon
and they do several orbits around the
moon people haven't heard of them
because they didn't walk on the moon
all right that's why they're not so sort
of high up in the list
but for me as the first people to ever
leave earth
they go into orbit around them and one
of those orbits they lifted their
hasselblad camera
and there was earth rising
above the lunar landscape and they
snapped that photo
and this was earth from
as space the universe could reveal it
to you right it's the flat disc
that it is
and so so but i knew what earth
looked like because i have
representations of it in my social
studies class
right earth has color-coded countries
on it earth has no clouds
earth has all these div all these
boundaries
drawn in that's what earth looks like
to me and to everybody else
and now down the pike comes this image
of earth from space not only apollo 8
but every apollo mission since then
has contributed to this portfolio of
earth
from space and we took a first look at
that picture
and there is earth alone in the darkness
of of space with no one coming from
outside
to help us to save us from ourselves
and there is earth silent alone
with oceans land
clouds i submit to you that
we americans the apollo program
nasa went to the moon to explore the
moon but we
discovered earth for the first time
nice i submit to you that a cosmic
perspective descended on us all
as a kind of a firmware upgrade
in our consciousness so
that picture comes out december 1968 we
walk on the moon
july 1969 and in 1970
what happens oh uh the
environmental protection agency is
signed into law
by a republican president by the way all
right
so why why didn't we have an
environmental protection agency in 1960
or 1950 or 1940 or 1965.
why then because the democrats
hate earth
so why why all right
let's keep going uh the national oceanic
and atmospheric administration
was founded in 1970 noah and before that
we had never really combined
the air in the ocean in the same phrase
before
this is a this is an early indication of
the interplay
between the the atmosphere the oceans
and the land
and noaa is charged with monitoring our
climate our weather in the service of
our safety our health
and commerce especially commerce that
relies on the seas
to bring goods and services across so
it was founded in 1970 so what else
happened oh
the comprehensive clean air act was
passed
comprehensive clean water act was passed
i got one for you 1971
we get that public service announcement
with the native american with the tear
coming out his eyes
yes all right that commercial he's
standing on the side
on the on the freeway and people throw
trash out
lands at his feet and there's a tear in
his eye
holding aside the fact that that actor
was italian let's hold that aside
that is one of the most recognized
public service announcements to not
pollute earth
now it's not like we only started
throwing trash out the window in the
1970s we were doing that in the 60s and
50s
but why then what what again this is
that
firmware upgrade that we all were
experiencing
in 1971 doctors without borders was
founded
it's got nothing to do with the
environment but why do they call
themselves
without borders where did that where did
that phrasing come
i submit to you that had we not gone to
the moon and looked back to earth
without borders they would have said oh
we're doctor international doctors
or globe trotting doctors something in
reference
doctors but without borders that's a
that's a mindset
that even gives it that name and yes
ddt would get banned when 1973
as wood leaded gas all of that happened
in the years we were going to the moon
wow
so i say to you what is the value
of this space program is it tang
is it velcro or is it a total
consciousness that maybe
earth is one ecosystem and we're all
participants in it and we have to do
something
globally not just locally to
ensure our own survival living in the
ecosystem that sustains it all
so so that's so and and so oh and of
course 1970 the first earth day
okay nice yeah all right and we've been
having earth days ever since
well man that is beautiful number one
that's a what a comprehensive breakdown
of the
history of earth day everybody should
see this video everybody should see this
video
and also everybody should see this video
so that you can understand the adoption
of this cosmic perspective
um with respect to looking at earth as
you know the home that we have chuck i
don't know if anyone
i don't know what everyone told you you
can't in the video that people are
looking at
tell them to watch the video in case
they're not watching the video that
doesn't work i guess because you
watching a video you need to go tell
somebody else to watch
somebody else okay right spread spread
the word
man i'm serious this is great stuff
because right now the only way that
we're going to see
a change in our human behavior is if
somebody from the united federations of
planets lands here is just like
what happened you guys you were doing so
well i mean we had our eye on you since
1970 and things were going really well
and then you just
i'm sorry
speak truth to power that's the truth
about it there you go
all right chuck we got to end it there
so that's
just great that's great a little bit of
earth day's birthday
excellent just turning today's birthday
actual birthday there you go back in
1970 originally they wanted on the
equinox um on march 21st
but it took some administrative delays
and timing to get it organized and
just by tradition now it's held on april
22nd worldwide
sweet yeah all right you got to check
well
we'll do this again yeah yeah this was
fun this was good all right
this has been a star talk explainer
video the earth day edition
neil degrasse tyson here keep looking up
you